biggest fireworks show is expected here
on the strip and is being put on
by the lvcva take a look here on your
screen
several strip resorts will shoot off
fireworks from the rooftop
hector mejia got a look behind the
scenes
we are getting a close look of the
thousands of fireworks getting installed
on the rooftops of seven las vegas strip
resorts including here
at treasure island as many as 80
pyro technicians are involved this team
is carefully wiring aerial shells
the individual wires function as the
electrical igniter
fireworks by guruchi says it typically
takes them an entire year to produce
the new year's eve fireworks display
this one for 4th of july will be
bigger that's despite only having just a
few months to work on it
precisely at 11 pm sunday the 8 minute
show will salute america's independence
while celebrating the city's own
independence from the coronavirus
shutdowns
the messaging we're back is the first
song starts off really strong
aretha franklin's in there freedom has
those elevations and movements so you
use the effects that
sort of low and build freedom freedom
and as it gets bigger and bigger and
bigger it grows bigger and bigger
all the buildings will do the same thing
and then ending with stars and stripes
which is going to rock
rock your chest you're going to feel it
the launching zone stretched from the
strat down to the aria
ceo and creative director phil grucci
says it's the nation's
largest fireworks stage in terms of
distance
after having such a dark pandemic year
many of us are ready to celebrate
it's exciting for us it's very very much
emotional for us as well
we're just like everybody else the last
year and a half we've been
devastated as far as our business there
will be no road closures on the las
vegas strip so you'll have to enjoy the
fireworks show the massive fireworks
show
from the sidewalk reporting from the
rooftop of treasure island hector mejia
8 news now
henderson is providing some
star-spangled fun with a fireworks
extravaganza at four different locations
around the city
and resort green valley ranch lake las
vegas and galleria at sunset
this all begins at 9pm